Pat forty back here on the show how you
doing Pat doing well rich ready for
football now you know you are and yet
it's interesting just like in the NFL
we're not talking about the actual
gridiron just yet you know the play is
right around the corner the stories off
the field the offseason non-playing
season stories that are just dominating
headlines and for good reason I want to
I want to hit you what you know right
now about what's going down at the Ohio
State University the Board of Trustees
getting set to meet tomorrow correct
yeah yep meeting tomorrow for a
discussion of all the recommendations
and findings from the the committee
that's been investigating how Urban
Meyer handled these X myths disaster
quite frankly and yeah then you know
we'll see from there what the timeline
is how long it will take the the
trustees and president to confer and the
president to make a decision on what
action to take if any you know most
people are expecting something Thursday
probably Friday at the latest possibly
even Wednesday but we're getting close
to an answer at least the question I
think is you know did how can Ohio State
actually do this end and find a way for
not at least some portion of people to
be absolutely outraged no matter what
it's such so what are you hearing what
is the ear to the ground here so far Pat
you know I I know this that the Columbus
Dispatch reported that there's been you
know a strong discussion of a suspension
no real timeframe given on that is it
you know is it the time that Urban Meyer
has already missed is it a game is it
two games is it a whole season I think
there's been some pushback at any sort
of additional sanction from Meyer but I
also know that you know there's been a
lot of I think the committee didn't very
thorough work and I think especially
when Courtney Smith came back with the
latest and most lurid round of
allegations against Zack Smith for some
of his behaviors that I think there was
a lot of concern within the the football
complex there that that meant that they
were
they were really kind of looking at
things beyond what did you know what had
urban do with the domestic violence
allegations and how much are they
concerned about just the overall
embarrassment of this whole thing to the
program so I think there's still kind of
a wide degree of uncertainty of exactly
what they're looking at and what they
want to penalize you well I guess Pat
forty here on the show the two questions
that I need I'm looking to see get
answered is one is that if zachsmith was
pulled off the recruiting trail by Gene
Smith because Urban Meyer did in fact
tell him what he heard about through the
text exchanged between Courtney Smith
and his wife at that is it is if that is
the actual accurate timeline of events
then why was he allowed to stay on staff
for as long as he did and then why was
he fired that's one piece and then to is
is I guess the the the similar aspect of
it is that what is Gene Smith's role in
all of this and will he will he emerge
unscathed
from all of this Pat no great great
questions you know the fact is you know
then nobody has disputed that that those
things happen that you know that Urban
Meyer was informed and that he you know
took it through proper protocol and that
zachsmith was brought in to to meet with
Gene Smith and then yeah why there was a
decision made that everything's fine I
don't know I mean that that to me
especially since if you're urban this
was a second domestic violence
allegation you know there was one in
2009 in Gainesville and and he was
actually arrested then although it was
not charged and that you know that's
always been the question to me is why
was there such a seemingly high
tolerance level for a guy that was
really a problematic employee and that
was before we even knew about some of
the other stuff and then yet she can
Smith's pardon Missy where does the buck
stop what did he do what was it what was
his actions and why was there no further
action taken there I I don't know I mean
I know Urban Meyer's in charge of hiring
and firing his staff like most coaches
are but especially a coach of his level
of magnet
but he also has a boss and a boss who
who would be able to you would
theoretically step in and say you know
we don't need this guy in our athletic
department but he did work for three
more years and so hopefully we get some
more explanations of that here but when
this and all this is wrapped up and what
do you think Pat are the odds that the
only lesson for Urban Meyer out of this
is that he needs to when he speaks into
a microphone understand that Buckeye
family is not the only group of people
in the United States that deserve a
proper explanation as to what's going on
inside the Buckeye Building and program
oh that yeah that could be his takeaway
from it and that's you know I I do
wonder and I had an athletic director
actually in another school asked me
somewhat cynically but if if urban had
just not lied at media day would this
thing have gone away I don't know but he
certainly absolutely did lie at media
day and yes if this was the Ohio State
fans sure don't care about whether he's
lying to the media but this is this is
beyond you know lying about whether or
not you get your running back as a
shoulder injury you know these are
fairly significant issues insignificant
allegations and quite frankly it was
found out very quickly that urban little
I'd completely about it and his
explanation for why he did was rather
unconvincing but is yeah if there's if
there's no more real sanction then
that's probably going to be his takeaway
so you know we'll see I you know I have
to think there's going to be something
more than him just missing three weeks
of August practice but I I don't know
we'll find out maybe this week as you
point out in short order Pat forty of
Yahoo Sports and then what what is
happening in in Maryland do you think I
mean DJ Durkin still out on the on the
administrative leave as well do you
think he ever sees a Maryland sideline
again Pat enough i I don't I would
anticipate that he's done it's just a
question of you know tidying things up
in a way that would make it a pretty
clear-cut decision you know I don't know
anybody kind of on the periphery of that
situation that doesn't think that's
going to be the outcome you know
people took note that the president an
athletic director when they did speak
about this they threw it basically all
on the training staff as opposed to the
coaching staff but when the strength
coach who is the right-hand man and
basically the philosophical facilitator
of what the coach wants done in a
program has been pushed out it's hard to
believe that the head coach isn't going
to be pushed out as well and it's
interesting you mean Sally Jenkins of
the Washington Post pointing out today
that ever since Korey stringer died of
heat exhaustion in an NFL camp 17 years
ago the NFL has not had another single
instance of that happening but 27 young
men in college football have passed away
do you think the NCAA and I know it's
always difficult to just turn to them to
try and legislate something that there
needs to be some form of uniform of
rules on campuses across the United
States to tell coaching stabs or
training stabs that this is the way
things are done you know I mean in an
ideal world yes and but you're right
though it it becomes this default like
why can't the n-c-double-a do anything
about it why can't the individual
schools do something about it why can't
I mean under what planet you know is
this sort of thing possibly conscionable
for it to keep happening over and over
again it's just it's astounding to me
you know it's happened in a number of
places I went to the University of
Missouri it happened there in 2005 they
settled a wrongful death suit and to the
best of my knowledge the training but
the head trainer from then is still the
head trainer now which is fairly amazing
George O'Leary survived a wrongful death
suit at Central Florida I don't
understand really how these things
haven't been taken more seriously
haven't enacted greater changes and
haven't really shaken the sport more to
its core if it is again another example
I think of just some of the the both
irresponsible nature and the soulless
nature of college athletics which we all
like and enjoy and want to think feel
good about but man there's a lot of
things that make you feel bad actually
so let's talk about what's going on on
the field best conference in college
football in
and 18 will be I think the big 10 you
know I just I look at it and you know I
know they've got a bunch of teens in the
top 15 in the polls and I think that's
legitimate
I think Wisconsin's gonna be very good
this year and I was a bit of a basher
last year but they're at least they're
gonna have to play some teams this time
around within the league Ohio State if
Urban Meyer is back on the sidelines
excellent team Penn State's gonna be
good
Michigan say it's gonna be good I think
Michigan has a big rebound season and is
much better
I think northwestern and Purdue Purdue
or sneaky you know I think this is a
really good year in the big 10 and then
your your preseason quartet to be
playing for it all would be some usual
suspects I'm afraid Clemson probably and
then I you have to look at Alabama and
then the question is to the SEC gets to
and again and I think there'll be
backlash towards that people be
predisposed not to let it happen so if
you take out Georgia which I think
really could be one of the four best
teams I would go Wisconsin in Washington
probably for the other two that's a big
Washington Auburn's a pretty big week
one game in then huge huge big that one
for Stuart because Auburn is a good team
as well in Washington sticking its neck
out going down to Atlanta to play them
basically in ovens back you how do you
think the Alabama quarterback situation
plays out because as you know one goes
down Nick Saban's not just going to what
do you say defecate out another player
as he said from his podium house that's
the soundbite of the year already on the
clubhouse but it sure seems like the
depth chart they're just they're just
they just grow out there it's
unbelievable pack yeah just trust the
poop process absolutely that's a great
teacher I you know that's the thing is I
wonder if some of the slow playing of
naming the quarterback might just be to
keep jaylen hurts or whoever doesn't get
the job on campus as opposed to having
them transfer immediately and try to get
in somewhere this semester and be and
speed up the process of being eligible
next year
but it's going to be a dicey situation I
expect to Otago tackle Aloha to win the
job but how happy is the backup going to
be uh you know this is gonna be one of
Nick Saban's I think most challenging
coaching jobs just from a standpoint and
breaking into coordinators on both sides
of the ball so that's one reason I'm not
picking Alabama number one I just think
they have a little more challenges than
Clemson right now always enjoy our chats
and love reading your material Pat
hopefully will chat a lot during the
football season
that would be great rich thank you you
got it that's Pat forty at Yahoo forty
the Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon
eastern on audience